a federal judge has just thrown a major
wrench in the democrats plans to
prosecute donald trump and rig the 2024
election by arresting the incumbent's
chief political rival judge aileen
cannon has suspended the doj's
investigation into trump until a
court-appointed official can review the
documents that biden's goons seized
during a raid on trump's home
this is a major problem for democrats
he because the democrats were counting
on speed to get their way here
because the raid itself was an
outrageous abuse of power and probably
illegal and because trump didn't commit
any crime in possessing the documents
and actually could not have committed
any crime in possessing the documents
and because whatever they accused trump
of having done we know for a fact
hillary clinton did it all with much
less of a right to do it all of which
has hillary on the defensive
quote
i can't believe we're still talking
about this
but my emails she tweeted
as trump's problems continue to mount
the right is trying to make this about
me again
there's even a clinton standard the fact
is that i had zero emails that were
classified
now the only problem with hillary's
statement here is that it is
completely incorrect as even fbi
director james comey a man who certainly
is not fond of donald trump and has made
that perfectly clear james comey
admitted
at the time
from the group of 30 000 emails returned
to the state department in 2014
110 emails
in 52 email chains have been determined
by the owning agency to contain
classified information at the time they
were sent or received
eight of those chains contained
information that was top secret at the
time they were sent
36 of those chains contained secret
information at the time
and eight contained confidential
information at the time that's the
lowest level of classification
in other words hillary stored lots of
classified documents than trump in a
much less secure location than trump
without any of the right to do it as
trump since unlike trump hillary was
never the president of the united states
and therefore never had ultimate
authority to declassify information now
she's telling bald-faced lies about all
of it which is nothing new
on every single issue from classified
information to election denial
to insurrection whatever the democrats
are accusing republicans of doing
the democrats themselves
have been doing for years i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from friendly
neighborhood snyderman who says the
members block interview is worth the
price of membership all by itself
probably the best interview i have seen
on the daily wire thank you so much i'm
so glad you enjoyed it for those who
missed it yesterday because you did not
subscribe to daily wire plus to get the
extra member block
we spoke to i agree i think this was the
most important and exciting interview i
have ever done period we spoke with the
man who just broke the guinness world
record for miles paddled on a river in a
boat made of a giant pumpkin
and i
truly if you have not joined yet this
absolutely should push you over the edge
it was a magnificent interview okay you
got to do it we do things on the member
block that you're not really allowed to
get away with over here on the public
social media where all the sensors are
in there trying to stop us from speaking
okay we've got to be able to protect
ourselves when i want to protect myself
you know what i check out i check out
ring summer and fall are very very busy
times people are away from home quite a
lot oh my gosh i've been traveling
everywhere and my travel schedule is
about to kick up i'll be gone eight days
a week i think
well how can i feel safe with ring of
course with ring you know about ring
ring has that wonderful video doorbell
where you can see and speak to whoever
is at your doorstep no matter whether
you're in the house out of the house at
the office on the beach on the other
side of the world doesn't matter well
ring also has an award-winning alarm
system
the ring alarm
takes security up to the next level and
then when you want to go even one level
further you can get ring alarm pro you
can be like me you can go pro cnet calls
ring alarm pro a giant leap for home
security so you're tracking not just
your physical home and the doors and the
windows and everything in between
but your digital home too so all the
data there you're protecting your home
with a really secure wi-fi router
do it right now okay this season go pro
with ring alarm pro learn more at
ring.com knowles that's ring.com
knowles
the hillary standard the hillary
standard
is what is uh
being described it's it's just a term to
describe
the two-tier justice system
probably best
exemplified by the clintons and had the
clintons get away with
i was going to say get away with murder
but maybe that's a little too real you
know i don't listen i don't have any
information that could lead to the rest
of hillary clinton please i've got a
family please
but the clintons get away with a whole
lot of stuff that the republicans never
ever would get away with and even beyond
the clintons the democrats get away with
a whole lot of stuff that the
republicans would never ever get away
with and then the democrats have the
temerity to accuse republicans of doing
exactly the sort of thing that they have
been doing for years you saw this
especially a couple of days ago with
jamie raskin democrat member of congress
who goes on cbs and he doubles down on
the biden line that the republicans
they're not they're no longer just the
loyal opposition the republicans they're
no longer just bad for the country
they're downright fascists
two of the hallmarks of a fascist
political party are one they don't
accept the results of
elections that don't go their way and
two they embrace political violence and
i think that's why
president biden was right to sound the
alarm this week about these continuing
attacks on our constitutional order from
the outside by donald trump and his
movement
two hallmarks of fascism again
i
had the same reaction that i had when
the white house press secretary used
that word i had the same reaction that i
had when biden used that word
none of these people certainly including
jamie raskin have ever read or really
even ever heard of the doctrine of
fascism that described by mussolini and
the philosopher giovanni gentile that
describes what fascism is none of these
people have ever read the early fascist
manifestos that came earlier
they they don't know any of this stuff
okay they're just they're not using
fascism to refer to an actual political
movement
an italian political movement that
really flourished in the 20th century
they're they're just using fascism to
mean something i don't like
okay there are plenty of political
movements that push political violence
and don't accept the results of
elections okay the communists have done
that there have been liberals who have
done that the democratic party in the
united states has certainly done that
okay
hmm who does that sound like not
accepting the results of elections and
peddling political violence but does it
maybe sound like the party that didn't
accept the results of the 2000 election
or the party that st hasn't accepted the
results of the 2016 election or the
party that didn't accept the results of
the 2018 georgia gubernatorial election
or on the political violence front maybe
the party that encouraged political
violence for eight months led by blm and
antitha or maybe the party where the
sitting vice president the current vice
president right now bailed out the
rioters in minneapolis or maybe the
party that called for for violent
democrats
and libs to go out and harass
republicans in public and at their homes
where their children sleep does it sound
like them sure sounds like them to me
and thankfully finally finally
peter ducey
the one kind of conservative reporter in
the white house press pool
asked the press secretary karine
jean-pierre about this because corrine
jean-pierre
has referred to multiple elections that
republicans won
as stolen
just trying to understand the new
attention on the mag of republicans you
tweeted in 2016
i was waiting peter when you were going
to ask me that question well here we go
you tweeted trump stolen election you
tweeted brian kemp stole an election if
denying election results
is extreme now yeah
wow so let's let's be really clear that
that comparison that you made is just
ridiculous i have been i have been well
you're asking me you're asking me a
question let me answer it and you said
ridiculous i was i was talking
specifically at that time of what was
happening with voting rights and the
what was in danger of voting rights
that's what i was speaking to at the
time
hold on before we get into
the
this fake argument the the thing that
sounds like an argument that she's
trying to make
just listen to those words there at the
end she goes
hold on hold on no it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous at the time
okay what i was talking about was voting
rights
and what was happening
voting rights what does i don't even
know what the semantic value of that of
those phrases are you said karine
jean-pierre you said that the 2016
election was stolen
and the 2018 election was stolen
so yeah i guess that has to do with
voting rights
if the if the election is stolen then
that undermines voting rights
sure
but
you
all of that is in service of the claim
that the election was stolen but now
you're saying that anyone who claims the
election is stolen as a fascist and a
threat to democracy but you not only
your political party 20 years ago you
yourself have done that within the last
four years
and her her actual response to this
because you you heard her tried to just
cut off peter ducey oh yeah here we go i
knew you'd ask about this yeah you knew
he would ask about this because it shows
your rank hypocrisy and how disingenuous
you are in your argument about fascism
and a threat to democracy
but she says no it's okay it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous
because it's not fascism when i do it
that's what the democrats are saying
yeah i the thing that i'm accusing
republicans of doing we
have done and continued to do but it's
bad when they do it and it's good when
we do it
that's what they mean
if the republicans are any threat to
democracy which which we're not but if
we were the democrats would be at least
as much of a threat to democracy and
actually much more of a threat of
democracy because they have undermined
and delegitimized more elections
if the republicans are a threat to
democracy because of the republican
political violence the democrats are
much much more of a threat to democracy
because democrats have engaged in
much much more almost infinitely more
political violence
than the republicans have
so what does this mean for democracy
it is a kind of threat to democracy
in the sense that
if if neither side
believes that the elections are fair or
legitimate
then we do then we do not have a
functioning democracy if you don't have
faith that the will of the voters is
being in some way some at least mostly
accurately reflected in the polls then
you don't have a democracy and the
democrats know that
they're just saying okay we're the only
ones who are going to question it
because we're going to remain in power
what they are saying effectively is and
joe biden said this
almost word for word
if you vote for the other party in our
two-party system you're a threat to
democracy that means we don't have a
two-party system anymore that means that
by our democracy they mean a
totalitarian one-party government if you
if you're not legitimately allowed to
vote for the other party then you don't
have a two-party system and you don't
have a democracy
they say democracy dies in darkness well
you're to die too someday that's why you
need a will right now go to epicwell.com
use promo code knowles you buy
homeowners insurance to protect your
house you buy auto insurance to protect
your car
what measures have you taken to protect
the future of your children do you have
kid insurance no that's not what you get
you get a will you've got to get a will
and i strongly recommend you get a will
from epic will a will gives you the
power to decide who will raise your kids
should something happen to you or your
spouse what happens with your stuff what
happens with all of your assets okay
without one the state decides what
happens to everything including your
precious little children if something
were to happen to you tomorrow how
confident are you that your belongings
will fall into the right hands have you
determined where your finances will go
who will take responsibility of raising
your children or caring for your parents
or your grandparents a will
may be your only opportunity to direct
important family heirlooms financial
investments and responsibilities to the
proper people in your life and it's
incredibly easy and affordable with epic
will
only costs 119 bucks for a single person
to create a will when you use promo code
knowles know wlas you will save ten
percent go to epicwill.com use promo
code knowles save 10 on epic will's
complete will package that's epic
will.com promo code knowles
big scare headline in the huffington
post looking down at our neighbors to
the south
forget about our democracy for a second
we're looking at brazilian democracy
far right bolsonaro
will test the limits of brazilian
democracy this week okay because he's a
far right guy and he undermines
democracy because most of the people
voted for him
so and when most of the people of the
dmos votes for the right winger that's
undermines democracy
because democracy is when the liberals
win even if no one wants them to win
brazil president jair bolsonaro
has called for mass protests on
september 7th a month ahead of the
election he's desperately sought to
undermine
okay hold on
so he's a threat to democracy for what
for two reasons
because he
is right-wing so even when the people
overwhelmingly support him he's
right-wing so that undermines democracy
and because he's calling for protests
but wait wait wait
i was told i was reliably informed that
protests are a great expression of
democracy that's the power to the people
isn't it
can you think of a political party
that has called for mass protests in the
lead-up to an election and that
encouraged them even while at the same
time they were telling all of their
political opponents to stay at home and
not go out because that was a threat not
only to democracy but to public health
they can you think of a political party
that said hey you
my opponents if you even go outside your
door you're a murderer if you go to
church if you go to work if you go do
anything outside you're a murderer
you're a threat to public health
but you my political allies we need you
to take to the streets for eight months
and not only protest but burn down
businesses attack courthouses
riot loot
rape murder all in the lead-up to the
election
can you think of a political part
because that's not what bolsonaro is
doing he's just he's just said on one
day you should you should go out and
protest
pretty modest stuff for a democracy
but i can think of another political
party
that encouraged eight months of protests
in the lead up but that it's okay when
the democrats do it
because the democrats have to win every
time in fact the only legitimate
elections are the elections that the
democrats win
and when the people vote for the
republicans that's a threat to democracy
that's not legitimate because to have a
democracy we have to have a totalitarian
one-party rule that's what they're
saying
speaking of those protesters you know
blm
is a social movement
yes i'm sure some of the people who are
involved at least at the lower level
levels of blm actually believe the kind
of party line
at the top levels of blm it has always
been a grift it has always been a con it
has always been a political
you scratch my back i scratch your back
kind of operation
and we saw this when patrice cullers one
of the co-founders of blm
was caught embezzling millions of
dollars and buying herself all sorts of
nice mansions in california that's when
blm rebranded from black lives matter to
by large mansions
we saw this
in all sorts of financial mismanagement
even other members of the blm
organization were getting angry at the
national blm group for stealing the
money you saw the people around george
floyd like george floyd's roommates for
instance they said look we never got a
penny from blm they never even paid off
george's bills these are people who
never met george floyd who were just
making millions of dollars from this
well now another blm leader is being
sued
for stealing allegedly 10 million
dollars
this is a top leader
in the black lives matter global network
foundation
accused in a lawsuit
of uh stealing 10 million through a
scheme of fraud and misrepresentation
this lawsuit was filed by another blm
group
blm grassroots
and uh it accused shalomia bowers which
is one of the one of the national
group's three members on the board of
directors of stealing the 10 million
bucks for personal use okay so now
what you have in this lawsuit
is not you know
what one group seeking justice and
another just one bad apple you know kind
of spoiling the whole group no you just
have
two
rich political operations fighting over
money this is like when a law firm
breaks up and they all sue each other
over money or any kind of company when
they break up and they're all just
trying to get as much money as they can
that's really what this is about and
that's what blm has been about from from
the very beginning and that's what all
of these liberal groups
are largely about how does it keep going
the libs in america believe such insane
stuff that the vast majority of
reasonable people do not believe you
know they believe that boys can be girls
they believe that white people are evil
they believe that we should kill all the
babies they believe all sorts of they
believe that we need completely open
borders they believe things that just if
you i'm obviously i think that's wrong
just as an objective fact to believe
those things but if you look at polls
the vast majority of americans do not
agree with these radical liberal groups
so then how do they keep going the way
that they keep going is not because of
the passion of the true believers the
way they keep going is because there are
financial incentives for them to keep
going because it's a massive power
structure that the libs have constructed
that works in tandem with its various
components
the democrat party works in tandem with
the liberal power centers in the
bureaucracy in the deep state they work
together with the militia down on the
ground the militia wing of the of the
democratic party of the liberal
establishment is blm is antifa and so
they go out there they encourage these
guys to go riot and burn things down and
they promise them you're not going to
get in trouble if you do it and then
they don't get in trouble they get their
charges dropped they actually get paid
to go do it blm made tens of millions
almost 100 million dollars
why because they burned the country down
that's why because they did the bidding
of the liberal establishment because it
created more chaos it created more of an
opportunity for the libs to take power
it raised all sorts of questions in the
lead up to the 2020 election it
intimidated conservative voters
and on and on and on the the libs have a
huge very well-oiled apparatus it's so
much bigger than the democrat party i
was thinking about this
when i was had the misfortune of
watching a clip from the view the other
day the the liberal
power apparatus is so robust they even
have their fake conservatives i was
listening to the new fake conservative
on the view is this woman named alyssa
griffin and she was the one who was was
just hired and she's she was supposed to
i guess she worked for donald trump
briefly and she's you know going to give
some balance to the network except that
alyssa griffin is just a liberal she's
just a liberal who puts on a clown nose
and pretends to be a conservative listen
to the way that alyssa griffin talks
about
her fellow conservatives and and the
most prominent conservative politician
in the country
they will twist and he will twist
everything around so that everything
comes back to him my only counterpoint
is this so i actually agreed with the
substance of his speech about democracy
and and there's pulling from nbc 57
percent of americans think the threat to
democracy is one of the most important
things the nation's facing i take a
little bit of issue with him broadly
applying the term semi-fascist to
republicans do i think donald trump's
a republican okay be specific okay
that's true right i think donald trump
is i think the vast majority of his
supporters are not i think they are good
people who want an economy that works
for them who saw more money in their
paycheck under donald trump and my fear
is this i think biden wants to be a
uniter but i don't think that that
speech was uniting
that's the that's the conservative on
this show that's the and look no one
watches this show so i doubt anybody who
watches or listens to my show or to the
daily wire or to dan bongino or to the
blaze or to tucker carlson or you know
any of the kind of conservatives i doubt
that anyone of those people
you people listens or watches
the view but the view is on network tv
okay the view still racks up pretty big
numbers for people who just have the tv
on in the background you don't even need
a cable subscription and this is what
they're hearing this is the conservative
point of view donald trump is a fascist
many of his supporters are fascists but
maybe most of them aren't fascists
that's it and joe biden wants to be a
uniter he just fell a little short of
the mark in the bidenhall putch speech
in front of the dark ominous red
backdrop where he called half the
country illegitimate and evil and a
threat to democracy
you know he just could have been a
little bit more of a uniter
really sad this woman who no one had
ever heard of before and now only some
people have heard of this was her best
shot
at
money and celebrity
for sure this was her best shot and i
even i realized i got her name wrong her
name is alyssa farah griffin though i
think women don't get three names some
no three names is it's too much
okay and it's usually the lib women who
want to have three names like ruth bader
ginsburg sometimes it's conservative
women like like any amy coney barrett
but no i'm sorry you only get two names
that's the way it goes christine blasey
ford i don't know no you get two it's
christine ford it's alyssa griffin okay
so this was this woman's best shot at
celebrity and money and she took it okay
i hope it was worth it i don't think
it's worth it
i don't think it's worth it at all but
there's just so much pressure to be this
woman she worked for trump briefly and
she thought okay if i ever want to have
a mainstream career
if i ever want to not be ostracized and
de-platformed and kicked out of society
i've got a call i've got to tow the
one-party line i've got to call
conservatives fascists maybe i can say
not all of them are fascists but i have
to do that it's why i can't get riled up
when the
the anti-trump conservatives the squishy
conservatives when the people come out
and say no well trump really he's bad he
said some things he shouldn't say i
can't get riled up trumpy upset norms
and standards yeah no not even he didn't
do
he donald trump on his absolute worst
day when he's indulging his absolute
worst instincts has not done one
ten thousandth
of the destructive sort of things that
the democrats have done and so i'm sorry
i just i just can't get riled up about
it he questioned the results of the
election yeah he didn't
he didn't
question the results of the election one
one hundred thousandth as much
as the democrats have in recent decades
and by the way they rigged the election
are we allowed to say that yet yeah they
rigged the thing they changed all the
rules before the election so no i'm
sorry i can't get riled up i cannot be
that woman i can't be that woman on the
view i guess i'm going to stick on this
show i'm not going to get a job on the
view you shouldn't either do not be that
woman
i cannot get riled up
about all the excesses of the
republicans and maybe you know maybe
trump shouldn't have said that and that
was kind of bad and they should listen
we just need to i can't get that riled
up
when i read a poll that one in four
democrat voters think that men can get
pregnant
that's a real number
this is a survey
conducted by wpa intelligence
ran august 22nd august 25th found
a full 22 percent of democrats agree
with the statement
some men can get pregnant
this percentage rose dramatically
when the poll only included
women
and then when you narrowed in even
further a shocking
36 more than one in three white
college-educated female democrats
agree with the statement some men can
get pregnant
you can't
you can't talk to me about trump's
tweets
okay you can't
you can't talk to me about how well you
know listen he's he's kind of divisive
you know and he raised some questions
about the 2020 election and i don't know
if i totally agree with his trade policy
and it will just it might be kind of
hard to support him you know he's so
brash
the the options for people to lead your
country
are
that that guy the guy who's like kind of
brash and maybe you don't agree with all
of his trade policies or whatever and
yeah he's you know he's kind of raised
some questions about the way the
liberals rule things
or the people who believe
that men can get pregnant
that's
that's not if you if you
presented with those choices if you
don't know which one to vote for you're
not a serious person okay forget you're
not a serious conservative you're not a
serious person
if you are seriously forget about also
the party that is wants to kill the
babies and the party that wants to flood
the country with foreign nationals and
the party that wants to destroy the
economy forget all of that the party
that says
one in four or one in three voters when
you narrow in
on the white college educated women say
that men can get pregnant i'm sorry
you're not you're not a serious person
if you if you do that
and i say those are the choices because
donald trump is 40 points up in the
polls for 2024. he says that he is going
to run for president he's he's all but
officially declared that and he's all
but officially said that he will run
even if they throw him in prison okay it
seems like nothing is going to stop this
guy from running and so it just seems to
me as a matter of political fact he he
is the alternative it's trump or
biden or whoever follows biden if biden
can't run but there are other people who
are suggesting that they would like to
run for president one of whom would be
ron desantis ron desantis running for
governor in florida just ran a political
ad that is getting a ton of excellent
reaction not only from conservatives but
even some liberals are admitting this is
a good ad
ladies and gentlemen
governor ron desantis
today we deliver for the people of
florida yet again
we saved our jobs
[Applause]
and kept us going they tried to shut us
down
but you saved our business thousand
dollar bonuses you had our backs and
honored our service you led by facts not
fear and you let us decide you let me go
to school you gave me a voice you put us
first and didn't let them keep us apart
you let us learn
you let us compete all of us
you protected our right to worship
together in person
and you raised our pay you protected our
waters and kept florida beautiful when
they attacked you you didn't cave you
stood strong for florida thank you thank
you thank you governor gracia
thank you thank you thank you thank you
governor desantis
[Music]
it's a good ad it's a good ad it's
almost like five to ten percent too much
and i know
one the only slightly negative reaction
i had when watching it was that the guy
in front of the church who said you let
us keep worshiping and in person and
it's it's nothing about desantis i just
thought oh my gosh is this how far we've
fallen as a country
that we need to run ads saying thank you
thank you for letting me go to church
is that could you imagine the founding
fathers rolling over in their graves
that that's where we're at right now
the great conservative accomplishment is
hey
you let us still show up to church on
sundays without too much harassment
and it is an accomplishment it actually
was a major accomplishment from ron
desantis because so many other people
squished on it
this is a good ad
why is this ad so good
because the ad is all about
well it represents people from all walks
of life all in florida not in an
officious kind of identity politics way
not in a you know i'm the black i'm the
black latina lesbian well i'm the you
know uh quadriplegic uh uh hispanic
transsexual pansexual and i'm the
representative of this group no the
groups that are being represented are
our teachers our first responders our
parents
are business owners all right it's it's
much much broader than just the kind of
racial or sexual identity politics but
the real strength of the ad
is
the ad is all about hey you did this
you did this you did that you did this
you did that
it's all
actual accomplishments i was up visiting
my grandmother over the weekend
and she just had the tv on kind of in
the background we weren't really
watching it but it was just kind of on
and i don't have tv i don't have cable i
don't watch the commercials that run on
tv ordinarily and so i see this ad and
it must have run
just in the day and a half i was there
it must have run two dozen times and it
was an ad about
the democrats have passed the inflation
reduction act which will lower costs
which will reduce the energy prices
which will save you money which will
restore our economy which will will will
will will
obviously it won't do any of that
the democrats outside of political ads
that are geared toward
specific voting demographics they don't
even really call it the inflation law
anymore they call it the climate law
because the inflation reduction act
study after study showed isn't actually
going to lower inflation it actually
probably will increase inflation
what'll it do well it'll protect the
environment now or it'll do all these
other nonsense things
so the democrats all they have to run on
is hey things will get better they'll
get better don't worry trust us i know
things got worse when we were ruling but
it's they're going to get better and ron
desantis can point to actual
accomplishments and say things did get
better i'm not telling you they're going
to get better in some indefinite future
they did get better i did things
that's a much more effective
strategy moving into midterm elections
the democrats are really struggling the
best candidate that the democrats are
running this cycle
the number one best candidate he's
running for senate in pennsylvania and
he's doing a pretty good job against dr
oz the guy's name is john fetterman and
he's running as a blue collar working
class democrat and it's a total bogus
identity the man's never worked an
honest job in his life and he got paid
50 grand a year in in
a an allowance from his parents to
subsidize his lifestyle
he isn't actually you know the guy that
he presents himself to be but even
beyond that john fetterman's in terrible
health he had a stroke on the campaign
trail he's never answered questions
about his health he refuses to debate dr
oz he he he can barely get out a few
minutes of speaking while he hits the
various campaign stops
i'm honored to be standing in the shadow
of your mirrors at your amazing
building
do you think of the 10 homes dr oz have
has a union hall
across
their home
say
you think the word of
steelworker
what words come to your mind if you say
steel workers of all the words that
bring to your mind when you hear the
word steelworkers does the word pretty
tan come to your mind
that's not a word that's going to come
to my mind credit
is wrong with demanding for
an easy
safe
kind of
their
income
so this is very very sad i'm not
certainly not going to make fun of the
man for
talking like a stroke victim because he
is a stroke victim and he doesn't want
to acknowledge that on the campaign
trail because right now he's the
democrat nominee this is his shot to
make it to the u.s senate and so he
obviously should be in some kind of
rehabilitation facility working on
getting his body back in motion and
getting his speech back but he can't do
that because he's on the campaign trail
this is it this is the election and so
they're going to prop him up for a
couple of minutes at a time and they're
going to try to minimize the political
damage of the fact the man cannot speak
and then they're just gonna try to use
the the weight of the democrat
establishment to force him into
washington d.c and maybe then he will
recover and maybe he won't recover but
it doesn't really matter because either
way even if the guy were in perfect
health he just would have been a rubber
stamp for the democrats this guy is a
radical radical leftist he said if he
had a magic wand the first thing he
would do in politics would be to let all
of the murderers out of prison
he said the the not he wouldn't cure
childhood cancer he wouldn't solve world
hunger no no the first thing he would do
is let murderers out of prison and so
he was always going to be a
rubber stamp for the the establishment
an avatar for the establishment all he
can talk about now
is this kind of silly stuff about his
identity i live across the street from a
union hall
i we're gonna support the unions
we're i'm pro-worker
what have you done what have you done
what is your record reminds me of ronald
reagan when he was debating jimmy carter
running in 1980
and jimmy jimmy carter peanut farmer
from georgia talking about all these
ponds
falutin so to understand us about
ourselves and who we are as americans
and ronald reagan kills him with one
line he says here's the question are you
better off now than you were four years
ago
that's all i'm going to ask well he did
it in a cool reagan way
well are you better off now than you
than you were four years ago and the
question cut like a hot knife through
butter because people looked around they
said no i'm not better off i'm not
better off under democrat rule these
democrats who are fear-mongering and
saying that the sky is going to fall if
the republicans take over kind of feels
like the sky is falling in on me now and
you look today
40-year high inflation you've got an
economy that's in shambles you've got
the first major war in europe in 70
years caused in large part by joe biden
even according to the ukrainian uh
president by vladimir zelinski you've
got three million immigrants coming into
this country every single year this two
million illegal immigrants pouring
across the southern border it's just
you are not better off now
than you were some years ago and if you
say it you're a threat to democracy
according to the libs as you know
as you know i consider myself uh quite
the sports connoisseur you know i i
put my knowledge
of uh you know my sum total of my sports
knowledge which is the new york yankees
from the late 90s to the early 2000s i
put that to the test i decided to join
the crane and company
football league
okay i've gone head to head against ben
shapiro
matt walsh andrew clavin
john bickley and the crane company guys
for the first ever daily wire fantasy
football draft now there's a lot
on the line here okay because the winner
gets like a nice gold tumbler that'll be
great okay you want but it's really you
don't want to lose because
the loser
the loser has to attend a wnba game
courtside yes the loser will have to
not joking this is real the loser of the
fantasy football league will have to go
and sit courtside at a wnba game wearing
a t-shirt that says equal pay
so
the draft air is tonight at 7 p.m
eastern 6 p.m central on craney
companies youtube channel make sure to
follow our league throughout the season
and support team knowles
team nostradamus to win
the whole
thing
speaking of workers rights
not not great news coming out of the
wall street journal turns out companies
are cutting back on maternity leave and
paternity leave
many employers are dialing down how much
paid time off they are giving to new
moms and dads
and the this is an issue that you're
going to see a little bit of a split
in the republican party and among the
conservatives between the kind of
conservatives who are
reciting the same the same old talking
points of
i don't know 10 years ago or 20 years
ago
and
that what's called the new right
the conservatives who are shaking things
up a little bit people like jd vance
people like
uh blake masters in arizona people like
donald trump for that matter
certainly the side that i i find myself
on much more
which is you know i don't think we need
to shill for corporations that hate us
anymore republicans did that for a long
time in the name of a free market or
whatever and it hasn't served us very
well no i don't think corporations have
the right to do whatever they want i
don't think that individuals have the
right to do whatever they want no matter
how destructive i don't think people
have the right to shoot heroin i don't
think people have the right to chop
their genitals off okay that maybe the
the conservative platitudes of 10 years
ago think that but the
what i think are the more serious
conservatives today are saying no you
don't really have a right to do that you
certainly don't have a right to trans
your kids you don't have a right to drag
queen story hour you don't have a right
to any of that kind of nonsense okay
there is more to life
than gdp and individual autonomy and by
the way the more that this woke
sickness infects our country by by
exploiting the platitudes of the free
marketplace of ideas and well the
private sector can do whatever it wants
the more that the wokeness virus just
spreads by exploiting that weakness the
worse it's going to be for gdp actually
and the worse it's going to be for the
economy and and every other facet of our
society okay so we're saying no there
are limits here we're not going to we're
not going to do that sort of thing
and you're going to really see it come
to a head with child care
okay child care is insanely
expensive
it is insanely expensive and so a lot of
people
certainly if you're a single mother what
are you supposed to do
what are you supposed to do you have to
have an income you got to be able to
feed your kid but then you got to do
something with your kid all day and so
you've got to send your kid to child
care but then the child care is so
expensive that you're going to have to
end up paying
much if not most of your salary to some
other woman to raise your kid while you
go out and scrimp and get a little bit
of money so you can feed your kid at
night
and this is true even for married
couples how many married couples can
support a family on a single income
not very many
not very and that's a terrible
thing blake masters is running in
arizona it's what really got me to be
interested in his campaign even back in
the primaries he ran an ad he said i
think that in america a major
conservative cause should be that you
support your family that you can support
your family on a single income
absolutely i think that would be great
and i think cynical corporations have
used the language of wokeness and
feminism and empowering women to to
force women into the workforce
to keep them away from their kids and
their families and to drive down wages
for everybody i am a huge supporter of
maternity leave
i think that if a woman wants it she
should have 18 years of maternity leave
or more depends on how many kids you
have
okay i think i'm with betty friedan
the american feminist who argued against
the french feminist simondo bevoir and
said women ought to be able to stay home
and raise their families if they want to
but in america today usually they can't
it's not it's not about forcing women
back into the home
a lot if not most women want to go back
into the home and raise their kids and
take care of their family at least for
some period of time in the kids
childhood and they're not allowed to do
that
but you used to be allowed to do that in
the united states it used to be possible
to support your family on a single
income this is such an offensive
headline to me companies are cutting
back on maternity and paternity what is
paternity leave
they're com they're cutting back on the
leave
all the while
they are
increasing subsidies for their employees
to get abortions ever since the dobbs
decision what have you heard companies
are are willing to pay for out-of-state
travel so that women can go access
abortion related health care
in other words i mean translate that
into english companies are going to pay
women to kill their kids why because it
helps the bottom line of the companies
because when the kids get born it costs
companies more money because the women
don't work as much and the women don't
work as hard and they're going to take
time off and they're going to take
maternity to leave and that's going to
that's going to affect the bottom line
and when you think of it at a macro
scale it's going to affect the gdp and
so you know it's worth it it's worth the
cost let's just kill those kids what
kind of a heartless society what kind of
a soulless society does that
and what kind of spineless feckless
conservatives would ever defend such a
regime
in the name of
the free market the the free market says
that we that the companies need to be
able to force everybody to the widget
factory all day long so that the
children can be raised at some clinical
institution when they're allowed to
survive in the first place and the
companies don't pay to kill them what
kind of a weak
pathetic
conservative movement would ever support
that
no what's the solution to this the
solution to this is not more of the free
market
okay
i'm i'm sympathetic to the companies i
don't think the companies should
necessarily have to pay for
you know
women or men i guess now and paternity
leave to take months and months of
leave time off no i don't think that
burden should fall on the companies
that's a political problem
it's a political problem that we now
have a country in an economy where women
are effectively forced to leave their
kids to someone else and pay exorbitant
prices and go work in the widget factory
for mr who who cares what his name is
that i i have to pay i have to go send
my wife to work for some man so that the
man can pay me so that i can pay some
other woman to raise my kids that's a
political problem it's insanity it's not
the way things just are naturally that's
a kind of new development over the last
50 years and we should use our politics
to change it create incentives that
allow women to stay at home and raise
their families and that create
incentives to not necessarily punish the
companies for that and and to stop
companies from from incentivizing women
to kill their kids we can do all of that
through politics okay
the people who say the government
shouldn't do anything at all ever let
the corporations do whatever they want
they're going to hate that but that's
over okay if that's conservatism then
we're not going to conserve a damn thing
speaking of companies cutting back
really sad story the bed bath and beyond
is closing lots and lots of stores and
the cfo
gustavo arnall
jumped to his death from one of the more
prominent buildings in manhattan it's
called the jenga building it's a really
hideous
talk about a dystopian place to to
commit a heinous and disordered act it
you know it's this
truly ugly building that's just the the
point of it is to be ugly and disordered
and not symmetrical or beautiful uh but
this guy jumped from the top of the
building
apartments in this building cost up to
50 million bucks
and uh he he jumped from it it seems not
just because
the company is failing financially but
it's uh also because the cfo guy was
just accused in a federal lawsuit
of a pump and dump scheme of
artificially inflating the company's
stock
and my first thought when i saw this
story obviously it's very sad for him
pray for his soul pray for his family
it's so selfish
so selfish suicide is always selfish but
this is especially selfish is my first
thought i haven't heard anyone talk
about this he could have killed somebody
he could have the guy jumps off of a
major prominent building in a really
populous part of manhattan island which
is one of the most populated parts of
america he could have killed somebody
doing that
but he didn't care which makes sense
because suicide is just a totally
selfish act
so of course you're only thinking about
yourself when you commit suicide even if
you convince yourself you're thinking
about other people you're not you're
committing a very very selfish act that
you have no right to do
now we're living in a culture that
encourages it
we're living in a culture where assisted
suicide is being legalized and and
encouraged throughout the country in
canada they're expanding assisted
suicide to children
really really selfish stuff
okay and it's it's being permitted by
the conservatives it's being peddled by
the libs
because the libs always invert morality
whatever is good they say is bad
whatever is bad they say is good
but it's it's really being permitted by
the conservatives
because the conservatives
are just throwing their hands in the air
on morality
the the libs invert it but the
conservatives just look away they say
well i don't know
i don't know they don't know nothing the
conservatives are know nothings when it
comes to questions of morality these
days
because they say well
look i have my own personal views
but i would never force my views on
anyone else who's to say
i think suicide is bad but maybe you
think suicide is good and so let anyone
do whatever they want
so pathetic
no conservative worth his salt would
have ever thought such a thing
before 20 years ago now that's the sort
of thing they say
it's okay they're useful frankly they're
more
they're worse than the libs in some ways
at least the libs are engaging in a kind
of moral dialogue and the conservatives
say well i just don't i don't have any
right to force my views on you yes you
do that's democracy
that's what democracy is is you forcing
your views on everyone else and everyone
else forcing their views on you and
there are limits to that you know
especially within our constitutional
framework there's certain
points beyond which you cannot go
but yeah you if you if you refuse
to articulate a moral view and force
your views on coerced people and if you
refuse to do that then then you're just
saying okay i'm not going to participate
in our democracy which is exactly what
the libs want that's what they're saying
too they're saying you have no right to
participate in our democracy well the
crazy part is the conservatives are
saying yeah i guess you're right i guess
you're right it's so squishy it's so
dumb don't do that don't do that
it's it's become so incoherent that some
people are
forget identifying boys as girls and
girls as boys some people are
identifying as frogs
the rest of the show is continuing now
you don't want to miss this okay this is
woke wednesday baby
we're going to be analyzing a trend
among
obviously deluded people who
they don't call it's not just a boy who
says i'm he i'm she or a girl that says
she's he or last week we covered people
who are using god god self pronouns who
identify as god
himself now people identify as frog and
i thought it was just one kooky person
and i wasn't going to cover it no there
are multiple people
it's now a pattern it's now trend who
identify
as frog self if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us we'll see you over there
[Music]
[Music]
you